hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar updates on primary aldosteronism
screening and use of direct renin i am
marie stone of labrads and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by diathorn to learn more visit
diasoren.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr brandi gonzalez pathology laboratory
utilization manager
special testing manager
physician laboratory consultant
director of specimen referral and
adjunct assistant professor
dr gonzalez you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone and thank you for joining
on uh this topic this topic is uh it's
near and dear to me it is
highly under recognized and you're going
to get to see that in this presentation
we're going to talk about primary
aldosteronism and the use of direct
renin concentration
disclosures uh i do receive a
compensation for speaking engagements
from deosorin inc
so the objectives today today we're
going to talk about uh
the rest system or the renin angiotensis
angiotensin aldosterone system
and how that system controls
hypertension
and how it it also
causes the increase
of your high blood pressure
and causing
a hypertensive disease
we're by the end of today you're going
to be able to describe and understand
key differences between
plasma running activity or pra assays
and the direct running concentration or
drc assays and finally we're going to
talk about some age specific cutoffs
for screening for primary dostronism
using the direct running concentration
assays
so first let's talk more about the ras
system
so this ras system is very critical when
you're talking about regulating both
blood volume and overall blood pressure
what this system does is it works to
elevate blood pressure when it's noticed
a decrease in the renal blood pressure
when there's been a decrease in salt
delivery
to the distal convoluted tubules and
then also when there's medications have
been given
to purposely decrease blood pressure
so yes when you're taking medications to
decrease blood pressure your body is in
a sense also still trying to counteract
those
and these different beta agonist
medications here
are working to decrease your blood
pressure more than what the rast system
is doing to increase it
so let's review the rast system just a
little bit
when your blood pressure falls
it triggers the kidneys to release renin
renin
then takes angiotensinogen and breaks it
down into angiotensin 1.
the angiotensin 1
then
works with angiotensin converting enzyme
or ace
to then create angiotensin
ii
now the angiotensin ii does a couple of
different things angiotensin ii one
causes your arterials to constrict that
begins to
increase the blood pressure
angiotensin ii also then triggers the
adrenal glands
to release aldosterone and vasopressin
vasopressin is also known as adh or
anti-diuretic hormone from the pituitary
gland
so these things then also
increase your blood pressure by causing
sodium retention
so you're looking at that where not only
is angiotensin ii causing the arterioles
to constrict but then it's triggering
other downhill effects that are making
you retain more sodium
and then
raise your blood pressure
all of this
constitutes
why we end up with hypertension
we end up with this higher blood volume
higher sodium and this causes chronic
cardiovascular disease
so why does this matter so well primary
dostronism is
highly under recognized cause of
hypertension most people go i haven't
even heard of primary aldosteronism what
in the world is this well the problem is
is that most medical education i mean
even you know what we're teaching our
med students and physicians they think
that pa is extremely rare
and it's not
it is highly under diagnosed and people
don't even realize that it exists in
2006
there was the primary doctrine
prevalence in hypertensive or the papy
study
and this study had
a little over 1100 patients that were
recruited
and they identified that 118
of those
1100 hypertensive patients
had primary aldosteronism so that was a
10 and a half
percent when you're looking at things 10
and a half percent of your hypertensive
patients that is an insane amount of
patients when you extrapolate that to
the general population
now there were some issues in this study
it was only
1121 patients so you when you're talking
about hypertensive you really need
larger studies to make that kind of
extrapolation and you need to look at it
across multiple different cultures as
well
but that is still a large number of
people
and when you're looking at the types of
primary dostrism they had
59 percent had adrenal hyperplasia
and 41 percent had an
aldosteronoma
which is a a tumor form
other studies report prevalence in the
hypertensive populations anywhere from
three to as high as 32
of all hypertensive patients
now there is a big problem with the
research that's going on in primary
dostronism and that's because they
they're very small
this 1100
patient study is actually one of the
larger ones that's been done out there
most studies on primary industrialism
have been exceedingly small and
therefore can't really extrapolate to
the larger population very well
and part of this is because people think
it's rare and so there's not a lot of
funding and there's not a lot of money
to really determine what is the extent
of primary industrialism in the
hypertensive community
[Music]
so since it's under recognized it's also
commonly missed
there was a cohort of 4 60 patients with
resistant hypertension
and only 2.1 percent were even screened
for primary dostronism
so if you're looking that between three
percent and as much as 32 percent
potentially have it
but only two percent are being screened
you have a very
large segment of the population that has
an undiagnosed condition that can be
treated
patients with primary adoptionism have
higher cardiovascular mortality they
have more cardiac events and need to be
treated more aggressively than non-pa
patients when it comes to controlling
their hypertension
the primary dostrom foundation which is
a patient-driven foundation regarding
primary dostronism
they have a current estimate of about
3.3 percent of all hypertensive patients
have
pa
you know well 3.3 doesn't sound like a
lot
but if you look at the entire population
of the united states
all of those states that are in red
that would equal 3.3 percent of the
population of the united states
so that six states population
would be
misdiagnosed that amount of people
you're talking about an insane amount of
people
that is being misdiagnosed as just
regular hypertensive patients
now you think about what happens
when a patient presents to their
physician with hypertension they get
screened with a blood pressure cuff oh
you have hypertension so what do they do
well we're just going to throw you
some medication and let's see how it
does
and they're not even taking the next
step to screen for primary dostronism
which is a very different treatment
so what are the different forms of pa
well there's two most common forms about
60 percent of patients are going to fall
into this bilateral adrenal hyperplasia
or bah
35 percent are going to fall into this
tumor-like
aldosterone producing adenoma
which does require surgery to fix
the other five percent are more less
common you've got this unilateral
adrenal hyperplasia
the familiar forms and they're five
different genetic subtypes of these
adrenal cortical carcinoma and then
you've got these ectopic aldosterone
producing tumors endocrine uh malignancy
type things
so there's many different subsets of pa
but the two most common are your
bilateral adrenal hyperplasia and
aldosterone-producing adenomas
so since we're not screening for what
should physicians really do when they
get that first that blood pressure
reading and they're diagnosing their
patients
with hypertension well before they put
them on any medications they really
should be getting an aldosterone and
running concentration
also known as arc
this is the best way to measure
and screen
for pa
it's best to do it before starting any
therapies even changing diets so you
don't want your patient to change their
diet and go on a sodium restrictive diet
because that can also interfere with all
of the testing
there's two different methods currently
available
for measuring renin as part of the
aldosterone renin
ratio
there's the old school way which is
plasma renin activity or pra
and then there's the new school way and
this is the direct renting concentration
or the drc
overall both are being poorly utilized
both are highly under utilized this
testing should be done during that first
appointment where hypertension is
diagnosed
[Music]
but why
well as i said earlier you know when
medical schools are teaching physicians
that this is a rare disease but it's not
it's not that rare so there's really
poor education regarding
both primary dostronism and thus poor
education regarding plasma renin
activity and direct written
concentration and since there's poor
education about all of it then this
leads into misinterpretation
of these tests
which also leads into more
miss and under diagnosis of pa you see
where i'm going it's a domino effect
here
so let's break down the differences
between
plasma renin activity and direct retin
concentration
so plasma running activity this is
remember i called it this the old school
test it's the tried and true kind of
considered the gold standard
this is usually a competitive one-sided
amino chemilus
immunochemi luminescent assay yes say
that three times fast
but it uses a biotinylated monoclonal
antibody
biotinylated
that word came really big into
laboratory medicine a number of years
ago why
because any assay that is biotinylated
reacts to biotin
has biotin interference
this the plasma running activity it
reports as nanograms per milliliter per
hour
or
overseas nanomoles per liter per hour
it is highly labor intensive
and highly time consuming to perform
anything that you're going to have labor
intensive you're going to have
variations between the technologists the
scientists that are performing this test
and because of this you have a high
variability between labs
this variability has an interlab cv of
about 35.4 percent so the result that
you get at one lab could be as much as
35 percent different
from another lab strictly because of
this labor intensive process
so what about direct running
concentration
well it's typically a sandwich
immunochemist assay using monoclonal
antibodies
notice the units are different it's
either a micro ius per milliliter or
nanograms per milliliter so the pra is
added the per hour
and that is not on the direct render
concentration
direct rendering concentrations tend to
be automated
they tend they are much faster not that
they tend to be they are they are much
faster than plasma running activities
and the direct running concentration is
standardized to the who is standard 68
356.
currently the reported interlab
variability on the drc is only 7.5
percent so when you're looking at these
comparing the pra to the drc you've got
less interference
it is much faster
less labor-intensive
less time to perform it is standardized
whereas the pra is not standardized and
thus your variability between labs is
much lower
the big sticking point here is you need
to look at the units
the units are vastly different which
means
you cannot compare results from one to
the other
you cannot compare aldosterone renin
ratios
using plasma renin activity
to aldosterone renin ratios using direct
reading concentration you cannot compare
them between each other
you have to look at them independently
so which one is better
well studies are now showing that the
drc is not inferior to the pra
and it's more practical to perform
so yes currently the pras still has that
gold standard status
but we know that those things do not get
updated very often
the studies are showing it is not
inferior the studies are showing that it
is much easier to perform it is less
time consuming
however you do have to watch on the
interpretation you have to do your
physician education when you do any
switch from pra to drc
because you cannot compare the two
difference completely different units of
measure
that's because they're measuring two
completely different things one is
measuring
the actual reading concentration the
other one is measuring the activity
so you must have
method specific reference intervals for
renin
and you must have
method specific
aldosterone running ratio reference
intervals as well
so what i'm going to show you now is
when my own facility brought in direct
renting concentration
and this was a comparison this is just a
snippet of the education that went out
to providers
you see the old test which is the plasma
written activity
[Music]
and what the reference intervals were
for that notice the nanograms per
milliliter per hour
the new test or the direct renin
concentration
and those
we report picograms per milliliter
and then
the ratios this is the new ratios that
we're using at our facility
with less than 10 primary aldosterone is
an unlikely and greater than or equal to
primary aldosteronism is probable
remember this is a screen
this is not a confirmatory this is a
screen
with all screens
you're going to have something that is
highly highly
sensitive
not really specific so you want to make
sure
that you do not make diagnosis strictly
from the aldosterone written ratio you
need to follow up any abnormal tests
from that
[Music]
so what about age
oh sorry it's there what about
age-specific
cut-offs for
the aldosterone renin ratio
so this changes throughout our life
these levels do
and the problem that we've run into is
that lower
ratio cutoffs
are really have high sensitivity
and decent specificity
in the younger populations
but as we get older
that specificity gets lower and lower
and lower
well that becomes a problem because as
we get older
the rates
of hypertension
increase
the older the more likely that we're
gonna have high blood pressure
as the population ages the more likely
that you're gonna see hypertension in
that population
so there's not a whole lot for lower cut
offs there you're going to miss
well let's talk about well if we do
higher
ratio cutoffs
you have a low sensitivity
but really high specificity in the
younger population
well about the older
well you still have high sensitivity and
you have a decent specificity
in the older population
so you you've got these this uh trade
and cut off it's a catch-22 situation
what do we do
so age specific cutoffs
helps to optimize this issue
but then the question is how many age
ranges should we really have
now if you remember a couple slides ago
i'm going to go back a couple slides we
have at my facility we started off with
with two age ranges we have 18 to 39
years and we have the greater than or
equal to 40 years
but there's some studies out there let
me move forward here we go a 2018 study
they looked across four separate age
groups so they looked at the less than
40
the 40 to 49
the 50 to 59
and then greater than or equal to 60.
and as you can see when you're looking
at that aldosterone renin ratio
and this is using the direct running
concentration
that the sensitivity and specificity
definitely changes with age
so
should we have more subgroups
should we have our subgroups of
not just greater than 40 and less than
40 but should we really have the 40 to
49
the 50 to 59 greater than equals 60.
should we have 60 to 69
should we have 70 and older
we don't really know
and while we're talking about it
we don't even have pediatric
ranges or
if we go back to the previous slide
[Music]
even at my own facility right now we're
only down to 18 years of age we don't
have
pediatric reference ranges you go well
it's pediatric they don't have
hypertension
yes they do
yes they do we're seeing more and more
especially teams with hypertension
and even
younger with hypertension look at our
good old american diet i know i'm in the
south
and we fry everything so everything is
full of loaded insult
we're seeing more and more hypertension
in younger and younger patients
so
should we really have age groups
not just less than 40 but maybe
30
to 39
20 to 29
should we have say 12 to 17
5 to 11 we really don't know
we haven't done the study we don't know
what
we really should have as far as those
age ranges
now here at my own facility we not only
have the
adult hospital but we also have
children's hospital georgia
and we're starting to collect that data
but for any of you that work with
pediatrics um may know is that you don't
really have a whole lot of leftover
specimen on your p's patients
so uh it's
gonna take a little bit for us to do
this and hopefully we'll see you know
what is
a reference range that we should have
for these on our pediatric patients
what would be the cutoff to determine
that they have
primal dostronism
having that cut off earlier
can get patients treated earlier and you
can prevent
cardiac issues later on we're seeing
cardiac issues
in 20 and 30 year olds now
this is something that us as
laboratories we really have to look at
and we really have to consider
so remember
aldosterone ratio that is your screen
what do we do to follow up for abnormal
screening
well there's several different types of
tests that you can do
to follow up on an abnormal
uh
concentration aldosterone running
concentration screen you've got your
oral sodium loading test which is
probably the easiest one to do because a
patient can do it as an outpatient and
just come in for the draw
you have your saline infusion test
and then you've got some other ones that
can do as well but basically anything
that would stimulate the various aspects
you can use
the various aspects of the rast system
you can use to confirm abnormal
screenings
now mind you that the confirmatory
testing can be skipped
and you can go straight to
adrenal imaging your radiology tests and
diagnostics if the patient had
spontaneous
hypokalemia
if that aldosterone is
greater than
20 nanograms per deciliter or greater
than 550 picomoles per liter
or
if the pra or drc
is
practically undetectable
a couple things you do need to
look at when you're looking at that last
one the very low and undetectable if the
patient has already gone
to a very low sodium diet
you may already have a very low or
undetectable pra or drc
so just mind you that you
in order to use vet
criteria the patient needs to be on a
regular diet
so what is the testing algorithm here
so you start with the adrenal running
ratio
and if it's normal
well pa is highly unlikely
if it's abnormal with normal aldosterone
then you should go ahead
and get that ct scan
if you've got a unilateral mass that
equals surgery if you've got a bilateral
mass then you can
proceed with bilateral abs testing
which is really cool we don't have time
to get into it here
but it's uh testing
both the right
uh adrenal vein and the left adrenal
vein for both aldosterone and cortisol
it's a whole lot more mathematics and
statistics and it's really cool
but that then determines if that's going
to be a surgical or pharmacological
treatment plan
and that's for your abnormal aldosterone
ratio with normal aldosterone if it's if
the aldosterone is elevated
or
you have that spontaneous hypokalemia or
very low undetectable pr drc you go to
the aldosterone suppression test
and if it's non-suppressible go to the
ct scan
if it's suppressible
then it's probably essential
hypertension
and not pa
if it's equivocal you're going to repeat
the suppression test in about three
months
so here's our testing algorithm
i hope you got a lot out of this today
this
presentation was to
give you a review of the rest system
to
talk about
the differences between the pra
renin test and the drc test and then
also talk about the age differences that
we really need to be looking at and
looking at our reference intervals
and how those are being applied to
patients remember clinician education is
key
regardless of which test you're doing
and you don't want to compare the two
values together
so i was told to keep it to about 30
minutes and we're
at 28 and a half
so if you have any questions i'll take
them at this time
well thank you dr gonzalez for your
informative presentation
and we'll now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
can i use patient samples measured by
pra
to evaluate a drc assay
so the short answer is going to be no um
you you can by all means use it as part
of your validation
but uh you're you're measuring two
completely different things while you
know
they're they're both fruits they're not
both apples so
um
yeah you really need to when you're
validating a drc assay you you need to
measure it against
uh another drc assay to validate your uh
your testing
all right thank you next question
which physician groups use the arr to
screen for primary aldosteronism
is this screen typically used by general
practitioners or specialists
so unfortunately it's most commonly used
by specialists which
that brings in a whole host of issues
when you get into
looking
at who's ordering it the specialist
especially in cardiology and uh
cardiology rarely orders it more
endocrinology than anything else
but um
what the people who should be ordering
this are your primary care providers
your family medicine
your internal medicine
even ob gyn as a lot of women use their
ob gyns as their primary care they
really should be looking for when they
get that first
um
elevated blood pressure and they're
going okay
this looks like
you've got hypertension before they
start them on any diet changes or any
medication that is the people who really
should be ordering
both aldosterone and renin and get the
ratio
because once you've started on
medication and once you started on that
low sodium diet
you really start running into
interpretation
issues and you're you're not going to
get as accurate of a reading as you do
with the patient being off of that diet
and off of medication
so
those of
those are the ones who really should be
using it and the ones
who are using it but by the time the
patient gets to them they're already on
medication so you've got a whole host of
issues there
i see thank you
um
next question
do you have any comments about pro-renin
um
i don't
uh
it's
not really utilized and i i don't really
see
where the clinical need is it's more of
a research need at this time perhaps
uh as more research is done you know we
might find a more clinical use for it
but currently
there's not much clinical use for it
all right thank you
next question
do you prefer arr in serum or plasma
uh so we prefer it in plasma
um it's
that that's
the reason that we prefer it in plasma
is that you can spin that specimen very
quickly
and the faster that you can get that off
the cells the more stable
that it is serum it does have to clot
uh before you can then spin it and you
start having some some issues
with the testing
when you're when you're looking at that
serum the quicker you can get that
plasma
off of the red cells the better your
results are going to be
okay um next question
can you comment on repeat requests for
renin and aldosterone testing when might
it be indicated and any specific patient
considerations eg time of day
so there are times uh especially when
you're doing like a mentioned earlier
the avs sampling where you're going to
do
multiple aldosterones back to back while
that patient is in a procedure
i have had a physician that
wanted renin's to be done on those as
well i think that was more for research
reason than it was for clinical reason
but for doing multiple adoptions in one
day that is a legitimate thing as part
of the abs protocol
as far as
doing them repeatedly like every few
days
if they did the first test and
they are really concerned about the
patient potentially having pa but then
they found out afterwards that oh well
you know the patient
uh
was still taking their medicine
and they
didn't come off their medicine like they
were supposed to they may go ahead and
repeat it
if the patient was
on a low sodium diet
and they didn't know that before
they may go ahead and repeat it
and then if you have someone who's kind
of borderline
and they're not really sure they may
repeat it you know after a few months to
see if there is a change
um
so there there are some indications for
repeating the testing
all right thank you
um next question
can plasma run and activity assays be
standardized the way that direct renin
concentration assays can
so
the short answer to that is no
um it would be very difficult to
standardize plasma in an activity simply
because
it is so labor intensive
standardized assays uh the way that they
can get them standardized is you
eliminate as much of the variables as
you possibly can and right now the way
that those plasma written activity
assays the way that they're performed
you simply can't
uh
in order to get
that that cv has got to come down to
even be able to try to standardize
plasma running activity so for that
reason the drc is
more
more favorable you've got not only is it
standardized
you have uh less
interlab variability
and because it is so much easier and can
be automated you can bring it much
closer to the patient you can actually
have it in
your local labs instead of
it only being a referral lab and by
getting those results back much faster
you can get patients treated much
quicker as well
all right great thank you
um it looks like we have one more
question
um and i again
i encourage the audience if you have any
questions please submit them and
we'll ask this question though is it
possible
for anti-hypertensive therapies to
interfere with the arr and if so
what should be done about it
so yes
anti-hypertensive therapies do interfere
with uh the arr both aldosterone and the
renin
there's a couple of things
one
like i said before you want to test
before starting therapy however if
you've got a patient that has already
started therapy
you need to look at two options
one is that you take them off of therapy
for at least seven days before doing the
test
that's really a consideration that the
clinician needs to make on a
case-by-case basis
and not do blanketly across patients if
you have patients
who have severely uncontrolled
hypertension and they would jump up into
you know
200 over 120 taking them off of their
antihypertensives is not an option the
risk for that is too high
uh
and those cases when you cannot take the
patient off of their anti-hypertensives
really the best thing is to bypass the
screen
and go straight to
uh doing a stimulation test
and looking for it that way
um
that those are really your your biggest
options
there
and it's really on a case-by-case basis
basis the clinician really needs to look
at their patient and look to see
is it safe for me to take them off for
seven days to see if i can do this or
can we put them
through a much more uh time-consuming
and troublesome test of doing a
stimulation
test
yeah it's it's going to be up to the
clinician on a case-by-case
basis right
well thank you dr gonzalez do you have
any final comments for our audience
sure so
uh as i did mention during the q a then
the drc is a test that can be
automated it can be done in your local
labs
so uh
if there's any lab managers that are on
here or lab directors i would highly
suggest that you look into those options
you can um
you know look and see what manufacturers
do have that test available to bring in
uh here at my facility
we have brought in both aldosterone and
direct running concentration and we have
an adrenal center here on site there's
only about five adrenal centers that are
across the u.s which means patients have
to travel long distances in order to get
that treatment the more facilities that
are able to bring this testing in-house
the more facilities are going to be able
to open up their own adrenal centers so
that patients can get the treatments
that they need
all right great
um and last minute we have one more
question
um
i gather most patients do not have low
potassium do you have any comments on
this
uh so that that's really going to be
in specific areas um i know in
our my own area here in augusta georgia
we actually see a lot
of uh
you know hypokalemia you could be
borderline
but um that's that's really going to be
kind of
area dependent and
you're going to have to to look and
develop your own
reference intervals
with your own patient population in in
those aspects
all right
well thank you again dr gonzalez for
your time today and your important
research
we would also
and we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor diasoren for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye